[音楽]
goo 2
私はございません
北山列が皆さんに質問があります
ここにあれば自分より置換表1に対して
これおかしいんじゃないよ mg じゃないの
そう思った経験がある人や曲げてみてください
ありがとうございますいっぱいいらっしゃいますねー
じゃあその人に猛暑としても増してください
これっておかしいじゃないよそう思ってても
これフォトセット面と向かって言えなかった
ガンスのかそんな経験があるかと
もう一度って割りてください
ありがとうございます
ここにいるみなさんも8
草の人はー
0時にエグゼなことに声はいうことができなかった
そう書いてくれました
でもより力もある一人人は権力や価値までねー
こんな風に嘘をしているように見えるのかもしれません
もしかしたら皆さんはこんな政策が多いですもんじゃないん
そう思った方もいらっしゃるのかもしれません
だけの私はそれは決して大谷そんなことなのかだなと思っています
なぜなら fg はときに人の命3を奪うの中です
phase リフ前にタイプ向けたがために起こってしまった痛ましい図形行動され
ました
それはー
rok 企業も新人とくださいなー
会社から長時間を強要され
自らの命を絶ってしまうという次元です
私はどんなにはいそれ
理不尽に打ち勝つことができる社会をつくりたい
そしてそのためにはここにいる皆さんという一人が偶然に立ち向かっていかなければ
ならない
でもそんな風には何出すからなんでしょうか
どんな武器を揃えればいいでしょう
私は今日ここに皆さんにその武器を
と何を揃えればいいのをお伝えしたいと思います
私がこれを伝えたいと思ったのは
私自身が活性 f 人にタイプ抜けてしまったために苦しい経験をしたからでした
私は2年8ヶ月前だ交際相手から暴力送られていました
毎日を繰り返しある高齢
能力
私は身も心もボロボロになっていきました
そしてそれは周りの人に影響していきました
ん
彼らもあって友だちと燃やせ約束を全部キャンセルしてしまいました
慶大も飛ばす言われて a
友達と連絡をすることができなくなりました
たまらず私のことはいけないことが思うようになりました
そしてそんな人とかはいたくないと思うようになり
私の周りからどんどん友達が
いなくなってしまいました
制裁になりた花なくて家族にも頭をなめりませんでした
2年を私のついに実家を出て彼と一緒に暮らし始めました
24時間の監視によって私は家族にも友達にも連絡を取ろうとしたを取らなくなってい
ました
でも今を私は彼から危ないことができました
私の前にはもう
私のことを間接でしたら能力を振る人を覚まし誰もいないんです
好きな時に h なと願いしてや走って死刑ものを食べて好きな人になって自分がやり
たいことを仕分けできる
そんな違うた毎日を送っているんです
あのときのことを振り返って体
なぜ私が日防ぎから3減らすことができたのか
立ち向かってきた行くことができたのかそれを考えてみると
3つの武器があったと私は気づきました
一つ目の時は私には家族や田村ずの他にもたくさんの見方がいたということです
私は彼は友達がたなってしまったら自分の見た狩野家からまいないじゃないかー
私は一人も死なないだそう思っていました
ある淵底カウンセラーの先生に出会いました
その先生は私にあなたは悪くないんだよ
そういえくれました
私はその言葉をきっかけにこのリグ水から抜けた方
そうキャップ位でしたんです
またあの時私は暴力により怪我をしてしまって a
弁護士の登板日線弁護士の人に登壇しました
ん
そしてその目ましょう
今まで人くらいに速います
3件葉っぱよは場所結成されることはありませんでした
3再生は私のために一生懸命
からと交渉してくれました
彼は私に社用車デイもう二度と会わないと約束光作れました
その結果私は
今こうして安全で幸せな生活を送れています
ここでを会社もしないわー
あなたの見方というのは
花持ちも
専門事はありえないということです
必ずしも具体的な回解決方法をアドバイスしてくれるような人がはなくてもいいんです
じゃあ一体どういう人があなたの味方として最適なんでしょうか
私はそれはー
あなたを責めない批判しないそんな者だと思っています
もしあなたなら自分な
pro c 練りと打ち上げた相手から
そんなものからあるんじゃないのオリカません
と言われたらどう思いますか
診断して明日にそんなことを言われるともしかしたら
打ち合わせ部内にももっと気づいてしまうかもしれない
逆に
相談してあなたは歌もいいんだよ
で仕上げた雪がすごいそういった前田はどうでしょうか
今まで行く前から逃げられなかった弱い犬
大嫌いだけでも少しでもスキーが変わるんじゃないでしょうか
見直してあげられるじゃないでしょうか
自分を肯定してくれる味方それは
時リフ前からに揺らす肉に立ち向かう
原動力になっていくんです
私が気づいた2つ目のときは
理不尽を
目に見える形として倉庫として残していたことです
私はー
誰かにこのことを相談しても
いやいやまさかあんな人が支援してもらえなかったり
ただの喧嘩なんじゃないの大家様んじゃない
そういうふうにとにあったられないんじゃないか
そんな風に思っていました
だから私は目に見えるか数で私が
職名した日封印を残しておくことにしたんです
暴力でお出かけさと破壊されたものを写真にとっておりました
終わり会を開いたら現金書留ておきました
ん
そんな積み重ねによって
作用分車各社は
私に
私も思っている以上に私のマヤにかかわらず一生懸命になって取り組んでくれたんです
もちろん自分の言葉で自分が直面したことに
ことを説明することも大切なことです
しかし
広くは時間がたてばたつ持っています
性格のことを説明するボタンを尽かしてまいります
また言葉は受け手の人にとっては違うミニくらいなってしまうことがあります
事例が一生懸命説明しても選んだカラーてしまうことがあります
そんな時にメニュー形で63の証拠があなたのいいタイプの
を減らすてになるんです
自分がいいかここというのはこんな風に手が届かない高いところにあるものなんです
じゃあどうやってこの手の届かないところにある
自分の言いたいことをとって誰かに渡せるのか
それは
こうやって一つ一つぷ証拠
階段をはめてい
それに乗っていけば
自分の言いたいことに譲渡を受けることができるのです
証拠はこんな風に一つ一つが積み重なって海岸のように自分が言いたいことを伝えて
くれます
自分の言いたいこと自分のいいたい
シートを代名詞てくれるんです
私が訪れた見込める抜きは
理不尽から抜けたとという勇気でした
ん
私は回もおり回もボールが怖いな
早く逃げだったらいいじゃないないよ
そういうふうに思っていた人もいるのかもしれません
だけど私は
てがチェック界の暴力が強なったけどそれから抜けたことはもっと怖がっ
近いされてもっと日々のみなんかもしれない
そう思ってしまっていましたん
午前が強いなぜの理不尽限り出すことが怖いん
中身で出さない中また理不尽な目に遭う
そんな悪循環に陥っていたんです
こんな循環に陥ってしまうとここからこのだから抜け出すことは本当に利益のあること
なんな
だけど第三者がいい
その苦しいねぇ人を無理やりそこから切り離すことは素敵ないんです
理不尽カーてゆな抜け出す形向かうという決断は
に偶然に苦しんでる人自身でしかできないのです
だから
こんな悪習慣をついてしまうとも自分で一歩を踏み出す勇気を
古いたかしてください
難しいことかもしれませんだけど決断村は
日本円を受けて黒線ぜひとその1次戦でしかできないことなんです
この一歩踏み出す勇気ことが私の伝えたい
3つ目の時です
冒頭に私は皆さんに
理不尽だなぁと思っていてもグッとこらえてしまったん
こんなを稼いと言えなかったその権限があるある方はいらっしゃいますか
を聞きました
そして皆さんほとんどなぁ
そんな経験があると答えてくれました
じゃあ今皆さんどう思いますか
私は今まで3つお気をお伝えしました
見方を集めて商工揃えねー
ここから抜け出さといういう息を一歩を踏み出せる気を持ってそうすれも僕にも私にも
軍事に立ち向かっていけるかもしれない
anan さんシャノンな力の場合でしまっていない
そう皆さんの意識が変化している店じゃないかと思います
その一人一人の変化が社会
同8そうでしょうか
どう社会が変わっていくでしょうか
日々文化や科学が発展して
新しいものがどんどん皆さん入っています
例えばは皆さんのを設けるスマートフォーフォー
毎日簡単にメッセージや写真がやりとりできデー
もしかしたら直接暴力や荻野フリオ
もっと簡単に
羽にも来受けた市は傷つけて傷つけることができてしまうかもしれない
そうやってどんどん
中に新しい理不尽が生まれていくんです
そしてそのリグ新しい午前に誰かは声を上げることによって
その問題の社会1され社会全体で a
その問題を解決成功と取り組んでいく
そんな運動が起こるんです
一つで終わりてみましょう
配偶者暴力防止校こんな法律があります
これは結婚二セール夫婦の間でご力が落ちた時にその被害者を守るそんな法律です
その効率の対象者
今まで夫と妻でしょ
だけど私のように交際相手から暴力思われて苦しい出したら
これはアリなことによって
社会に交際相手の暴力という問題が
資料たり
誠意
この法律のて対象者は
東京しているカップルにまで広がったんですねっ
理不尽で苦しんでる人も来たが
言われて頃クイズを出して声を上げることによって
公演が変わったんです
高円寺なぜがありません
これは内閣が東京タワーをみなさん国に行きたいかーしゃす
ない僕は
チェーン対する暴力防止のシンボルカラー洗う
紫で東京たを買ったしました
そうやって女性いらっしゃる暴力をなくそうと呼びかけたんです
そしてその中には交際相手からの暴力というのも含まれるようになりました
政府がでがありません
このがの方に登っていきましたん
実写や民間団体多くの人が交際が豪力という問題に取り組むようになったんです
リフ前に空新鋭人が雪を出して声を上げることによってい
効率が変わりましたん
人の行動を変えました
社会全体が変わっていったんです
大学生のとき校閲を勉強していた私は
私が号列を使って何かを達成は他の前を助けることにつながるかもしれない
私が暴力を使って自分に打ち勝った
精霊を作れば
社会を変える手助けできるようと押せない私はこういうふうに社会入ってだけ
たい
そう思って私は前後生になりました
ここにいる皆さん一人一人が
日風情に3つの武器を使っていう気を揉んで立ち向かっていけば
社会わー
はいは余裕方向に進んでいく私はそう思います
そして私は
法律を使ってサイモン氏として a
で午前に立ち向かっていこうとキャプりしたしばしと一緒に
またが息づきていきたいとおもいます
ありがとうございました
th
goo
ああああああ